today we're talking about tau vms data
ingestion and app sheet in gmail i'm
alicia and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
in june we announced a new virtual
machine family tau vms that extends
compute engine's vm offerings with an
option that delivers the best price
performance among leading clouds for
scale-out workloads
the first member of the tauvium family
t2d is now available in preview
this week we're excited to share the
results of independent testing by
pharonix validating google's claims on
price performance leadership check out
the blog for more
developing cloud-based data ingestion
pipelines that replicate data from
various sources into your cloud data
warehouse can be a massive undertaking
that requires significant investment
we have defined principles for data
pipeline planning to begin the process
these principles are intended to help
you answer key business questions about
your effort and begin to build data
pipelines that address your business and
technical needs
app sheets new capabilities within gmail
are powerful because apg is a true no
code platform and anyone can create one
making it easier than ever to translate
a great idea into software and deploy it
to teammates in an easily consumable
fashion app sheet apps can be connected
to the data source of your choice like a
google sheet sql database or salesforce
imagine how useful it'll be when
creating a dynamic email because you can
update data in any of these sources
without having to leave your inbox
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you